forests are incredibly important they
supplies with a wide range of goods and
services including food and fuel and
fiber compared to humans forests are a
lesser understood component of the
climate system in it determining of
climate our challenge is not only to
understand that but to help societies
understand the degree to which their
health and livelihoods are dependent
upon the health and livelihood of those
four systems you know Forest Research
tended to be highly focused and it was
focused on timber production and the
ecology that you learned related to the
trees that you were interested in and
and nurturing those for us so that
they'll produce lots of timber so
certainly for most of the 20th century
that was how science was applied and it
tended not to look at the forest as a
system at all but rather well maybe as a
system but as a production system for a
particular outcome would and you know
what we see today is much more interest
in the forest as a complete system
forests are incredibly important as
reservoirs of carbon we in contrast tend
to admit carbon to the atmosphere both
by burning fossil fuels which of course
is our major source of emission but by
causing those forests which can be so
important to be destroyed and amity and
we can they in turn emit carbon we think
perhaps that about twenty percent of
global carbon emissions due to
deforestation which is almost entirely
provoked by human activity as shown in
illustration here recent estimates
suggest that protected areas currently
protect about fifteen percent of global
terrestrial carbon but we know that this
particular areas aren't all managed in
such a way that they actually protect
carbon we know that there's land use
change going on inside particular area
so finances needed both to establish new
protected areas and to improve the
management of existing ones I think
forest management policies can be
crafted to MIT to help mitigate
it change provided we understand the
full suite of influences of force on
climate for example some of the things
they've been talked about of late is
avoided tropical deforestation or even
tropical reforestation and the idea here
is that the tropical forests are benefit
to climate through high rates of
evapotranspiration that cool the surface
and of course through carbon storage
that reduces atmospheric co2
concentrations but we don't really yet
understand how these two processes
themselves interplay and what the net
balance of those two processes are and
then there a variety of other ways that
force tropical forests are influencing
climate say through aerosols and fires
and reactive chemistry that we have only
just now begun to explore ecological
forestry is sort of a you know an
evolution that's occurring right now in
forestry and it's an effort to base
Forest Practices much more on natural
stand development processes including
disturbances so we've learned a
tremendous about about how natural force
developed over the last 30 35 years and
it hasn't really been incorporated in a
lot of forestry practices and there's a
substantial community of for scientists
and managers now we're trying to begin
to truly incorporate what we know today
the greening of climate models refers to
the fact that these models include plant
ecology and atmospheric models require
fluxes of energy moisture and momentum
at the land surface as boundary
conditions to solve the numerical
equations of atmospheric physics and
dynamics the early generation climate
models were a geophysical framework and
primarily excluded the influence of
vegetation on surface fluxes here we see
the greening of the planet over the
course of the day through photosynthesis
as the Sun comes up we see the planets
beginning to photosynthesize and you can
see a wave of greening moving across the
planet as the Earth rotates and the Sun
gets higher in the sky
I over the course of a year you can also
see the greening of the planet and that
certainly in the northern hemisphere
plants are dormant during the cold
season and there's little photosynthetic
activity as temperatures begin to warm
up in springtime the leaves emerge and
the plants begin to photosynthesize and
we see greater carbon uptake and then in
the fall as temperatures cool down again
we see the loss of leaves and lower
photosynthesis there are a variety of
tools and methodologies available to
look at forest influences on climate one
of the most important systems that we
have is called eddy covariance flux
towers and these are sensors towers that
are put up in forest and make rapid
measurements of heat moisture momentum
and carbon dioxide exchange with the
atmosphere they can also measure solar
radiation and long wave radiation and
they provide a really high temporal
resolution to picture depiction of
forest atmosphere interactions over the
course of a day and then when extended
over periods of months to years they
allow us to look at the seasonal cycle
of forest atmosphere interactions and
interannual variability and the response
of for say for example to drought or
heat waves there are many challenges
involved but the first one is getting
everybody to agree that's going to take
some time because there are lots of
different interests involved and lots of
different visions they will need to
agree both on what the mechanism itself
looks like and about the technical
methods and definitions that underpin it
and that's going to really take some
discussion another major challenge is
nature of leakage which is this question
of if you halt deforestation in one
place are you actually halting
deforestation or are you causing it to
move somewhere else we refer to this as
leakage it can be international local in
scale and it's a real problem both
making sure that we avoid it and making
sure that we know about it when it's
happening national capacity to implement
any of these measures to reduce
deforestation is a serious worry for
many countries as is the governance to
make sure that the financial resources
are getting to where they really need to
be
and finally all of this is in the
context of conflicting and increasing
demands for land for agricultural
production especially biofuels for food
supply which mean that the demands and
conflicting needs for land put
additional pressures on forests
prioritization is a really important
element in the way we choose how to
spend financial resources for reducing
emissions from deforestation we need
these approaches to show us not just
what to do but also where to do it and
where additional resource where
pressures may be displaced and where
additional resources may be needed to
help us secure the full range of
benefits from forests and other natural
ecosystems and so what we really need is
we need to develop a science that
integrates the multiple ways in which
forests influence climate with an
understanding of the their forest
response to climate change itself before
we can craft sound forest management
policies to mitigate climate change I
would have to say we have not developed
a comprehensive vision internationally
any more than we have nationally of of
what force can do for us with regards to
carbon and it's substantial but of
course it's more complex than most
people would acknowledge so it's going
to it's going to change tremendously
what we do what we choose to do but our
policies are going to really determine
how that plays out hopefully those
policies are going to be based on truly
comprehensive objective science in this
special issue on forests find news
reviews and perspectives on forest
dynamics using for us to mitigate
climate change forests of the past the
changing governance of the world's
forests and much more
you
science is published by triple-a s the
science society